alors matthieu delormeau toi tu as
rejoint l'émission va revoir qu'à
premièrement mathieu est ce que tu te
rappelles en quelle année tu as rejoint
les missions je dirais il ya cinq ans
pile donc 2000e 2000 2014 2015 en 2015
2015 2015 je suis en train ne retrouver
ça moi mathieu mais tu sais koné du
début soit est drôle c'est que nous on
avait tellement vrai qui était en face
de toi sur france 4 est tellement vrai
c'est un carton débuts en première et
deuxième partie de soirée une seconde et
5 600 milan 2e ps et toi tu me connais
des fours sur france 4
j'étais content je te connaissais pas
j'ai bon c'est bon le petit nouveau qui
arrive on le dégage
merci au revoir et la coupe s'est
inversée est d'ailleurs tellement à
verser qu'on était absorbé que
maintenant je suis chez toi mais bon
mais c'est vrai qu'au début début on
était en phase et nous ont cartonné et
après tu m'as tu m'as tu es ce que tu te
rappelles tu entretiens d'embauché avec
moi comment tu ailles t'embauche était
drôle c'est que j'avais été viré d'nrj12
est en fait qu assez donc je sais pas si
tu le savais par le patronat nergie je
pars de chez moi tous tristes eu dans la
rue et tu m'appelles or on s'était
jamais parlé avant j'ai pas ton numéro
de téléphone rien et tu me dis je t'ai
vu sur nrj12 tout ça j'aimerais bien que
tout est dans l'émission voyons nous
jeune rendez-vous à l'époque chez bny
'j'ai j'arrive on passe le fait est
exactement 1h36 de retard 1
j'attends bas avec les filles de la
réception charente et après qu'on se
soit ils me disent tu as très bien quand
tu seras le monsieur sérieux de
l'émission le monsieur médias sera
toujours une cravate et une veste on te
prendra au sérieux
six mois après j'avais de plume dans le
cul mais tu regarde ta rentrée et juste
après on a des surprises parce qu'on à
thierry moreau qui va être avec nous
c'est parti regardez mathieu allez bon
va l'accueillir tout de suite allé
battre
[Applaudissements]
saint mathieu honnêtement oui rav-ner
100 rue quand vous êtes hyper v l'air
mais non mais t'as entendu des trucs non
mais juste pour commencer avec
christophe plus dans trois secondes
je veux quand tu veux dire que tu es
demanderait c'est vrai parce que je
produis dans une voiture il ya à mes
yeux tu produits de la mer ce qu'on
voudra mais on sait accueillir les
nouveaux voilà matthieu delormeau et je
me rappelle de ça et franchement et
mathieu je voulais dire 'est-ce que tu
kiffes avec nous et mathieu dangereux
médecin tu m'entends tu m'entends est ce
que tu fabriques où il faut mettre le
son mais je suis a très bien pu ce qui
est rigolo c'est que la première
première première avant d'arriver j'ai
vu mon avis fogiel et je lui dit qu'est
ce que je vais faire dans l'émission
qu'est ce que je vais dire j'ai pas de
valeur ajoutée jeu super deux émissions
et même dégagé et il m'avait dit voilà
sois toi-même tout ça et si j'avais su
pas penser que six ans après je serai
toujours là ce serait qu'on aurait vécu
tant de choses oui j'avoue que c'est
hallucinant hallucinant avec tout ce
qu'on a vécu
je te parle pas de dégâts si je parle
pas de l'hypnotisme à l'hypnose pardon
bref oui les amis rencontrés rené gosse
de jean vilar j'adore tout le monde mais
on sait tout le monde que j'ai envie
c'est mon coup de coeur